so you want to see something cool check
it out this is a POI or at least it was
a POI now it is part of a baton or a
staff rather how exactly does this work
well flowtoys has just released a new
system that allows you to swap back and
forth Parts between different props and
essentially invest in one set of lights
that you can use with multiple different
types of props it is called their pop
and flow system and I have a set of the
props to review and share with you
today Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm coming at
you with a review of a system that I
know has been in the works for quite
some time that's right the pop and flow
modular system so buckle up we're going
to dive in but before we I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- bus friend of
the channel Becca Becken thank you so
very much for supporting my my channel
my work and my mission so clearly
there's a lot of promise to this idea
but how does it actually work in
practice well that's what I'm here to
talk to you about today so I'm going to
go through my usual review rubric I'm
going to give you features ease of use
brightness battery life durability I'm
going to give you some personal thoughts
and of course rattle through the price
and of course interpers with all of that
I will be showing off some footage
showing you what these props actually
look like so let's Dive In
features so this right here is the basic
unit of the pop and flow system this is
what they refer to as a Spoke it's a 16
pixel essentially like Rod that has this
little flare that goes from skinny to
wider on it they have a few different
options for what the incaps can be but
by and large this is the basic thing
that you're looking at and what it has
up top here is this little kind of uh uh
divot and flare and this allows you to
connect these spokes to a variety of
different what they call Hubs the hubs
are essentially uh parts that have
receptacles in them for these little
divots right here so you can just pop
the prop
in and lock it and you're good to go
spinning with it so in theory what you
do is you get however many spokes you
want and the specific hubs that you want
for whatever props you're going to spin
and you can just pop them in and out as
need be now all the hubs have a little
button on the tip of them that allows
you to turn them on and control them as
well as turn them back off as well as a
little micro USB port as well to
recharge them there's a variety of
different endcaps that uh flow toys has
available to put on the ends of these
spokes this is the mediumweight version
right here these are just the
traditional flow caps there's also a
smaller version that uh has less weight
to it and there's also the Hefty version
which is uh these kind of capsule cone
assemblies right here here um depending
upon how much weight you want to put on
the end and what kind of feel you want
your props to have the spokes themselves
are running the exact same software as
the capsule 2.0's as well as the vision
props so every mode that they're capable
of doing these are capable of doing as
well including connecting to the flow
toys app by way of their Bridges and
being able to program specific shows if
you would like to using the pre-existing
modes that they have built into them and
that is something to emphasize right
here these are not technically
programmable po that is you cannot
download custom images or messages into
them you have to make do with variations
of the modes that are already built into
them but that said what these actually
excel at is producing really beautiful
Trails regardless of what props you
decide to put them in and of course one
of the great Promises of these is that
since the system is modular you can not
only swap out for different props but
also you can break your props down to a
smaller size so rather than walking
around with a big uh 34 in staff I can
collapse it down to something that's
going to fit inside of my backpack which
is super handy there are honestly
probably more features that I'm
forgetting about right now I'm doing
this off the top of my head so if you
have additional questions about these
please leave me a comment and let me
know ease of
use being as how these are running the
same software as the capsule 2.0's as
well as the vision props you know
turning it on and finding a mode that
you want is a pretty easy process you
know they respond to a button press you
find the specific mode you're looking
for and you're good to go right now that
said if you want to get deeper into the
programming process including how
exactly you're going to find alternate
versions of these modes and adjust them
and edit them as well as adjusting
brightness and things like that you're
going to want the documentation if you
can get access to a flow toys bridge in
order to use the software to avoid
having to figure out the combinations of
button presses to get you through
various modes and how to edit them I
highly recommend okay so how about EAS
of use for swapping out parts of
different props well I will be honest
with you you when I first got my uh sets
of these pop and flow props from flow
toys um the fit between the hubs and the
spokes was so tight and so close I was
terrified to try to pull them apart I
kept thinking that there must be like
some kind of locking mechanism but no
you just yank hard enough and they come
right out once you're over that initial
hump and you're down to just push the
two parts together until you feel that
click you're good to go and it does have
to be said that that click feels really
really satisfying when you get
it
brightness so like all flow toys props
of this generation they're pretty bright
they get bright enough that it helps to
have some additional illumination around
you cuz they will definitely knock out
your night
vision battery
life okay so usually the trade-off when
it comes to Bright comes with the length
of the battery life and uh longtime
viewers of this channel will know that I
have two tests that I give every single
LED prop that I come across in order to
test both how well it takes the most
punishing things that you can do to the
battery as well as what an average use
case is more like so the first use case
where I basically just punish the
battery as much as I can I turn the LEDs
to the color white and put them up to
full brightness and wait and see how
long it takes for them to die out
entirely these props got to an hour and
a half and on the other end of the
spectrum very literally the second test
that I do is to set the LED POI to a
rainbow mode that way they're going
through all the different colors and I
put them onto medium brightness you want
to guess what the big difference here is
you get all the way to 9 hours of
battery life so keep that in mind as
you're using these there are absolutely
ways to get a much much much better
battery performance out of them if you
play your cards
right durability
so a lot of the Hub connectors are 3D
printed which always makes me just a
little bit nervous I talked to Sean from
flow toys about this and what he told me
was that the specific process that they
are using to create their hubs is such
that uh you get more life out of them
than you normally would but by and large
Flo toys props are always super durable
I don't think I've ever seen them let
something out into the world that isn't
able to take the kind of punishment that
I can Dole out so I expect no less from
these
feel do I enjoy using these are they fun
to spin with and have I found myself
spinning with them more often than I
thought yeah actually I totally have in
particular when I opted for the uh flow
cap with the FPC uh tether hubs there
was something that happened with this
that felt kind of magical um
there's something about this combination
of weight distribution that I just found
felt really pleasing for me and uh
you've probably spotted me making tons
of videos with them in the past month
specifically because I've just been
enjoying using them and I wanted to find
more videos to use them in it's also
really awesome to have staffs that
really can collapse down and that you
don't sacrifice the feel of once you put
them back together that's really really
rare and I'm really impressed that they
solved that problem some of you out
there might be wondering about these
capsule and Cone POI and how closely
they feel to traditional POI and my
answer to this one is kind of mixed
these have been engineered with enough
weight on the end to get them really
really close to feeling like a
traditional set of Po I definitely find
that when doing things like hybrids and
uh a lot of tech moves like that that
they feel pretty close to traditional
POI once the length of the head and
especially if it is a rod shaped form
factor gets past a certain length
there's a little bit of wiggling that
happens as you enter into a stall that
is just
unavoidable so I personally don't find
these uh a great fit for a lot of my
stall based work but you might find they
work differently for you that said I'm
also at the point where I'm kind of
enjoying just playing around with
pendulums when it comes to longer form
factor po like this so that's not that
big a deal to me um I've just been going
with the lighter weight ones overall
when I spin and that's been working out
for me just fine so one of the ways that
these really Excel are when you turn
them into stabs or as they're referred
to on the site batons now any of us who
have ever played with modular or
collapsible staffs know that what winds
up happening is the pieces kind of
rattle around a little bit in the socket
and it feels a little weird and
uncomfortable so you have to make that
choice between portability versus a
solid feel for the product and you know
what they totally nailed it with the pop
and flow system
when you put all these pieces together
it feels like one solid unit it's
glorious um I don't feel the seams at
all when I'm spinning these the one and
only note that I will put in here is
just that uh the Baton SL staffhub that
I got is hollow plastic and because of
that it's a little flexible and I can
definitely feel that as I'm spinning
them I can feel the two ends wobbling a
little bit due to the flexibility not
due to the connection but due to the
flexibility of the center here now flow
toys does have options for staffs that
have a carbon fiber core to them and
that will eliminate that wiggling
problem so if you're interested in the
batons I highly recommend getting the
carbon fiber core uh into the middle of
them it will help make the staff feel
more solid to
you
price all right so I actually wound up
with so many options here that um I'm
going to have to refer to my notes to go
through all of them and what the
individual prices of them are so I hope
you'll bear with me here so first and
foremost uh Popp and flow poy with the
Smithy rope hubs and tethers uh go for
$380 over on the flow toys website um
the pop and flow POI with the FPC
tethers are
$390 a pair if you want to add flow mass
and uh the capsule shells uh excuse me
the Pod shells with these little cone
sleeves and everything um that'll run
you
$420 a pair um and if you want a set of
the pop and flow batons which are really
double stabs but uh I guess they're
using the word tons now um yeah so a set
of these is going to run you
$780 um and if you want to acquire all
of the things that I have here alart
that that is four spokes uh two Smithy
rope hubs two FPC hubs and two baton
hubs it'll run you a total of
$910 so there you go you can find all
these over at the flowtoys website at
flowtoys.com and do remember that I have
a promo code with flow toys if you use
the code drexfactor
3224 at checkout it'll get you 10% off
whichever props you happen to be
purchasing and it helps out the channnel
so everybody wins and now how about some
more footage of those pop and flow props
in
[Music]
action
n
[Music]
cool so do you have any of the pop and
flow props what has your experience been
please leave me a comment and let me
know also this last bit doesn't really
fit anywhere else in the review but I
just thought I'd put it out there flow
toys has one of the best warranty
systems that I have found in the flow
Arts world so do bear in mind that if
anything goes wrong with your props flow
toys will uh go above and beyond to make
it right and make sure that you're still
out there flowing so keep that in mind
uh when you think about purchasing these
two did you get anything out of this
review if so please remember to like
comment share and subscribe so other
people can find it and of course to help
my channel
[Music]
grow
this video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing patreon supporters in particular
I would love to give a shout out to my
flow patrons who are listed on screen
right now if you like the videos that I
create uh regardless of whether they are
flow sessions reviews video essays Etc
and you'd like to see more of them
there's an easy way that you can make
that happen and that is to go sign up
over on patreon at
patreon.com direct factor pooy to
support my creating them
a lot of times I have to do stuff to uh
make make it so I can pay rent and uh
bring money in the door and that
involves doing things like private
lessons or my live stream lessons things
that take me away from being able to
invest more time in creating my videos
so if you want to see higher production
levels of my videos if you like to see
more of them then go sign up on patreon
and let me know that that is a thing
that is important to you and that you'd
like to see me invest more time in
please and thank you if you'd like to
see more of my reviews on a variety of
different L props I will include a link
to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on YouTube thank you so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow yourselves today regardless of
what props you're using and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace